[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et qui sait
et je trouve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
tout le monde joue les mains un courrier
par endemol
[Musique]
cousin
les tables
avec sa mort
[Musique]
m
[Rires]
[Musique]
je promène mon chien les mecs
la démarche est tu as dis je m'élève des
chaussettes mais je suis le fan parce
qu'elle met des claques à tarek failli
intervenu en eau espère ce que tu as tu
danses le chalet qui fait oublier la
rust avec un ofni pas si les craintes
mais la personne dans cette rue
dumouchel et pas quand il est passé de
voiture
[Musique]
mon
quant à elles chuté
[Musique]
on
je n'ai pas
[Musique]
bah oui c'est le grand retour de la star
mondiale et 10%
donc c'est la blague 2,4 photo bon bah
sinon tu fais moscato tout ce qu'on voit
dans les airs au caire la capitale des
états unis doc c'est à washington
[Musique]
[Rires]
le président apparence à cyril qui veut
être président à la mise en culture
[Musique]
y est elle est dangereuse pour moi je
t'attendrai sexy savez quand je suis six
mois josiane verlaguet marraine
je suis bien devient l'une des marraines
des marraines française darmon qui me
crève lui prendre wipro là et alors que
toi que je reviens bien que ce genre de
ce quotidien j'ai traité comme un chien
dit qu'on n'avait pas de nom selon la
[Musique]
cei a plus de problème ce qui m'a appelé
ce matin il m'a dit tu mets personnage
fait qu'astra mieux ok on appelle les
choses c'est un bel hommage au dr
[Musique]